aujourd'hui si les frères barbey pas de
bruit aux fourneaux pas de service ni
même de conversations animées avec les
clients une routine depuis le 14 mars et
le début du confinement chef passionné
bon vivant et bienveillant depuis huit
ans julien est à la tête de ce
restaurant en banlieue lyonnaise pour la
première fois depuis trois semaines il
est venu à son établissement mais pas
pour cuisiner au restaurant est fermé
depuis le 14 mars et aujourd'hui j'ai
ouvert les grilles du jardin du
restaurant pour que les clients qui ont
passé la commande auprès des producteurs
locaux puissent venir récupérer leurs
paquets ou leurs cagettes de fruits
légumes un restaurant mis brutalement au
régime par l'épidémie du comité 19 au
total avec son frère claude il gère
trois restaurants et 30 employés tous à
l'arrêt en ce moment c'est sûr que rue
ça fait mal au coeur ça fait mal au
coeur de voir son sang reste offert mais
ne pas pouvoir accueillir légende pas
pourra partager quelque chose avec les
gens ensuite chez un restaurant
fédérateur dont je vois beaucoup de
monde de tout horizon et que ouais ça ça
nous manque
bien sûr ça nous manque on va pas dire
le contraire si on n'est pas en vacances
on n'est pas en vacances même si le
restaurant est fermé le matin je me
réveille en dix ans
j'aurais bien demain les au boulot pas
pour julien la question de continuer de
travailler avec des livraisons à
domicile ne se posait même pas face à la
gravité de l'épidémie
ces pertes par mois se comptent en
dizaines de milliers d'euros nous avons
décidé de fermer pour des raisons
économiques c'est-à-dire que ferme
l'emporter ça engendre des frais
des coûts par rapport à un chiffre
d'affaires qui serait quand même
dérisoire par rapport à aux dépenses
donc le calcul est vite fait les barbes
n ont jamais connu un tel séisme en
cuisine et ce ne sont pas les seuls dans
cette situation la profession en a pris
un coup à lyon pour une ville qui se
veut la capitale de la gastronomie
française
la pandémie est une catastrophe
économique quelques établissements
demeure tout vert avec des livraisons à
domicile mais la plupart d'entre eux ont
baissé le rideau à contrecoeur